("Charmeuse" by BAMF)
- [Gary] Here.
What's up man, how are you?
Really good, man.
Glad to connect again.
Thank you.
I'm getting to the point, I'm in
a very sad place in my career.
I'm getting so many emails,
so many five-minute coffees.
You know and it's scary
because with DailyVee,
I'm showing some of them
which, as you can imagine,
only feeds the
beast even more, right?
Because if I'm sitting there
and I want to meet with me,
and I see some guy and I'm
like I'm better than that guy.
I'm gonna do it.
Yeah, it's really, really
tough and Shultz is right.
And I'm still different,
like, I want to actually,
I kind of, you know it's funny
like I was wonder if my life
will change and I'll just wake
up one day and not want to buy
the Jets but instead actually
have that five minute coffee
with everybody on Earth which
is weirdly interesting to me.
Like I would really enjoy,
I mean I really would.
I really would.
Problem is it's not a good
business and I don't want to
monetize my audience so...
Alright, I'm gonna shower.
- [DRock] I can go wait
in the lobby if you want.
- Yeah.
In Austin, Texas.
First day of a
pretty intense week.
Austin to Boston tomorrow,
connecting in Atlanta and then
speaking at Inbound.
Huge event.
Then taking a redeye
that night to London.
Full day in London, insane
day in London at the office.
Bunch of new business meetings
and then a jam session
with some clients.
Then on Thursday to Lisbon,
Portugal to speak at Web Summit.
Humongous event,
one of the biggest
if not the biggest in Europe.
Fly to New York connect
and actually I think I have an
overnight in New York.
Which will be great to be home.
Then go to the Bahamas, catch
the boat that is Summit at Sea.
Really funny, all my friends
were for hitting me up
last couple weeks.
They're like,
"You going to Inbound,
"Web Summit or Summit at Sea?"
I'm like, "All three."
They're like, "Yeah, right,"
'cause all of them are actually
the same three days.
One's in Boston,
one's in Portugal,
one's in the sea but
that's how we hustle.
("Cheerleader" by BAMF)
Dude, I'm so fired
up we're doing this.
- [Lance] It's gonna be good.
How are ya?
- [Gary] (hands smacking)
Really good.
- [Lance] Three
years in this house.
- [Gary] It's great.
Serious glasses, I like it.
Great, we gonna do the podcast?
- [Lance] Yeah,
down in the cellar.
Dude, look at that haircut.
We got to move some furniture.
- Yeah, he's all about
everything has to be approved.
- He's doing it right.
- [Woman] Hey, you can
help us move furniture too.
- [Gary] So good to see you.
- Oh, you were waiting
for muscles to show up?
- [Gary] Listen, I'm ready.
I got guns now.
What do we need?
We got more stuff?
- [Woman] Yeah, our
nanny got married--
- [Gary] I heard.
What do you need?
This is, I'm pretty
excited about this.
We need some
different kind of footage.
- [Man] It's good content.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Lance] Good job, man.
- Thanks, brother.
- DRock, get this.
- DRock, this is
the good footage.
Watch your head.
- [Man] That was close.
I'm not tall enough to
usually have to watch my head.
- [Gary] I'm excited
about the wine.
What are we drinking tonight?
- [Lance] We got
to look through it.
- [Man 2] If we're doing
these podcasts in Austin,
we tape them all in here.
- [Gary] 'Cause the
sound is just awesome?
- [Man 2] Sound's good and
there's no distractions,
no kids, no...
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- [Lance] GaryVee,
thanks for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
- I almost feel like we should
talk about why we're here.
It's kind of cool.
- I totally agree.
I'm also pumped because this
setting is very cozy for me.
This is basically,
this is like my upbringing.
All this wine around
me, I'm very excited.
- And all the listeners, they've
seen the pictures so they know,
they kind of get a sense.
- They got a sense of
what's going on here?
It's awesome and for all the
people that are listening for my
world that come
from the wine world,
there's some
pretty legit shit here.
We can curse here, right?
- Yeah.
- Oh, good.
- I don't.
I normally don't.
- Yeah, that's fine.
I'll curse for the both of us.
There's a lot of
great wine here,
so I'm excited.
Yeah, we've got a
wine dinner tonight.
- Yeah.
One thing, two things--
- [Gary] Please.
- One, 'cause I watched
a lot of your stuff and
you talk a lot about process.
- Yes.
- For me, I talk
about this shit too.
Process is, and we've talked
about it on this podcast a lot
with other people but
the process of that build,
that's the thing.
That's all I ever cared about.
- You're preaching my brother.
Honestly, I made a
video that says,
that is recorded, that when
I buy the Jets I'm gonna deploy
and it's gonna be a young me go,
be old as shit when I buy the it
and it's gonna say,
"This is the worst
day of my life."
- 'Cause the process is over.
- 100%.
- Yeah.
- I love the journey so much.
As a kid, with girls in
junior high and high school,
it was just trying to
get them to like me.
- Yeah.
- I'm so obsessed
with the chase.
("Cheerleader" by BAMF)
- Alright, I want to
go drink some wine--
- [Gary] Okay.
- with you and all our homies.
- [Gary] Me too.
- That's a collaboration
I did with them.
Let's do that.
- [Gary] Oh, shit.
Let's do that. Great.
So, one--
- [Lance] That's '05.
- Three.
We have 13 you said, right?
- [Lance] Yeah.
- [Gary] Alright so
we need three of each.
- [Lance] So those all '05?
- Checking, no one's an '06.
You have another one, you think?
Oh yeah.
'06, may have to do '06.
'05, alright.
- [Lance] Okay.
- [Gary] Three of those, good.
- [Lance] I'll put these...
- [Gary] Want to
do '04 Darioush?
- [Lance] So when
I bought this--
- Yeah?
- [Lance] I drank
it in '06 or 07,
if fucking sucked.
- '04 was a tricky
vintage early on.
- [Lance] This now--
- Is killing.
A lot of the '04s are killing.
- You know, in '06, '07 it
was super caramel-y and--
- It was also tight and awkward.
It was a disjointed vintage and
then it kind of came together.
Yeah, you're good.
- [Lance] Okay.
- Alright.
- What is going on here?
This is not clean, bro.
- What do you
mean it's not clean?
This is how I do it.
- I know with all that
shit hanging around.
- You mean this?
- No, this, you can
take the knife thing and
cut it and throw it--
- I don't do that.
By the way, you
don't understand,
if you weren't here, this
is what I would normally do.
(group laughter)
This is, honestly,
this is literally, literally,
literally how I open wine.
I have no time and that's it.
- [Man 3] One of
those electric ones?
- I'm not fancy.
And then I go like
this and that's it.
- [Lance] I got to go upstairs.
- [Gary] This is not
like some fancy restaurant.
- [Lance] I'll be up
here making a vodka soda.
- [Man 2] That's what Lance
talks about is the processes and
the simplicity in the life.
That's like what we talk
about what we miss the most.
You always hear, "Oh, you
miss it blah-blah-blah."
- Right.
- [Man 2] No, we miss the...
("Barren to Sprout" by
The Muse Maker)
Every day, wake up.
- [Gary] I think that's
the beauty of what I've got.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- [Gary] I think mine's a little
bit more wide than that kind of
a mission but
I kind of got that here.
- [Man 2] But what I'm saying is
that was the epiphany for me was
that I figured out
how to (inaudible).
- [Gary] Apply it, 100%.
- [Man 2] It's the same thing.
- [Gary] I think so.
- [Man 3] That was impressive.
- [Gary] This one is
not gonna get split.
- [Man 3] First year,--
- Ooh.
- [Man 3] Oh, there you go.
Nice work.
- [Man 2] Wow, Garyvee.
- [Man 3] Done
this once or twice.
- Still got some old tricks.
- Local vineyard and
I brought it back,
put it in my bike bag and
shipped it on the plane and when
a bike was coming out on a
conveyor belt all I was thinking
was please don't
be dripping wet.
(group laughter)
Please don't be dripping wet.
- [Gary] But I'm a truebred
entrepreneur and by my
definition that means
somebody who likes losing.
Meaning I think of myself much
more as a UFC fighter than
I think of as a boxer.
I like boxing more even though
that's not a popular thing to
say but I also think that in
boxing when you get a loss,
it's like a
scarlet letter, right?
You're like finished.
In UFC, everybody has losses.
That's just part of the game.
And I associate in that
sport more as an entrepreneur.
There is no great entrepreneur
that doesn't have losses.
It's not even the cliche shit of
like you learn from your losses.
Fuck that.
It's just that it meant
that you can take chances.
I'm not here to be like
you learn from your losses.
I'm here like,
"Oh, you have no losses?
"You didn't take any risk."
Which means you're on defense or
you're on passive mode,
which is even scarier.
You're in the middle.
I almost wish you rather be
defense than being stuck
in the middle, so...
What up, gang?
5 A.M. L.A.
Thanksgiving weekend brewing.
Anyway, real quick, hope you
guys got to check out the full
interview with Lance.
If you didn't it's linked in
here and what do you guys think
about the daily format?
And the shorter?
We got some in the queue but
we'll start banging them out in
real time very shortly.
Much love.
Best Thanksgiving ever.
("Barren to Sprout"
by The Muse Maker)